hey guys welcome back in this video
we're going to talk about lemon juice
and your pH okay so now there's some
confusion about lemon juice since it's
citric acid it's why is that good for
uric acid what an acid help an acid well
in the body lemon juice turns into an
alkaline substance so it alkalizes okay
and uric acid is the byproduct of
certain protein called purine and
purines are high in liver organ meats
like liver and kidney game meats turkey
sardines seafood like herring scallops
beer and caffeine and other things as
well but those are the main ones and all
that turns in the uric acid now it's not
just a matter of you eating those foods
resulting in uric acid crystals which
turns into doubt there's really another
reason these are aggravating factors and
it has to do with your way that your
kidneys are processing this uric acid so
there's two other big factors that I
find that if you can correct these you
can still get away with eating these
foods and not end up with high levels of
uric acid which turns into gout which is
pain in the big toe and other joints
insulin when the insulin is too high you
have high levels of uric acid that's why
if you have insulin resistance you're a
diabetic a lot of times that comes with
high uric acid and gout okay and then
ketosis the thing that I'm recommending
everyone actually do it can actually
give you too much uric acid as well so
simply because the ketones compete with
your gases and tend to go back and forth
and the chemistry that ends up with high
levels of uric acid so you don't need to
know that all you need to know is that
you need to start consuming more lemon
juice in your diet to keep your uric
acid low because your the citric acid in
lemon juice neutralizes the uric acid
crystals okay so it actually improves
gout so yes you can make sure you
eliminate eliminate these from the diet
that make sure you just add the lemon
it's really really
simple it'll actually help you keep the
uric acid very very low so thanks for
watching